And these last two chunks of code actually add the visual elements to the page.
Notice here that bar is simply a bunch of g tags that have
some transform on them.
We have not actually put any rectangles on the page or
any labels on those rectangles.
But since d3 has this nice chainable syntax.
And since any call to append puts elements within the element append
was called on, in this case bar.
We can add direct angles inside of the group tags.
And this last chunk of code simply adds the textural label which corresponds to
the value of the data point.
That was all I wanted to cover from a high level of this code.
And just wanted to expose to some of the d3 functions and
methods that we haven't encountered yet.
And how to apply them to data loaded from an external file